[Musique]
once I was s years old my mama told me
go make yourself some you be once I was
old I don't
know
the
down the
rivers you find
love and
honesty
[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation bonsoir et
bienvenue dans zone Europe sur sensation
en partenariat avec
tv78 une émission spéciale enregistrée
vous l'aurez peut-être deviné si vous
avez reconnu la petite sirène statue de
bronze icône de Copenhague au Danemark
le Danemark pays d'un peu moins de 6
millions d'habitants membre de l'Union
européenne depuis 1973 mais pas de la
zone euro ici la monnaie officielle
c'est la couronne danoise zone
Europe et voici le sommaire de cette
émission 80 % des Danois pense que faire
partie de l'Union européenne est une
bonne chose on verra pourquoi avec Maya
Nilson vice-présidente des jeunes
Européens Danemark pourquoi choisir le
Danemark pour faire une mobilité on ira
à la rencontre de Flavie 21 ans elle est
ici pour faire des études en digital
management et puis à Noël les rues
s'illuminent pour créer une atmosphère
féérique et les animations sont
nombreuses nous vous emmènerons faire un
tour à la Bruens ice rink patinoire de
600 m car en plein cœur de Copenhague et
à la fin de cette émission nous irons
assister au spectacle organisé par
l'association les chansons françaises au
Danemark une soirée festive et
culturelle à l'école franco-danoise de
Copenhague vous verrez zone
[Musique]
Europe
on se retrouve maintenant au Musée
national du Danemark un bâtiment situé
au cœur du palais du prince construit au
18e siècle ce musée a été inauguré en
1849 et on va en savoir plus avec
metoboritz zone
Europe bonjour comment allez-vous ça va
merci super vous êtes responsable des
expositions du musée pouvez-vous nous
dire où nous
sommes nous sommes au Musée National à
copenhag c'est l'un des musées les plus
importants puisque vous pouvez y voir
des objets quite à la préoire et
d'autres beaucoup plus
récents les Danois sont-ils les
successeurs des
Viking certains voudrai dire oui en
effet mais les Vikings sont juste une
période dans l'histoire danoise nous
avons des objets ici qui remontent à
cette période c'est une partie de notre
histoire pourir sur le musée que peut-on
voir
ici vous pouvez voir une grsee la
culture danoise où nous vivons ce que
nous faisons depuis les temps les plus
anciens jusqu'à une époque plus
moderne ce musée il s'adresse à
qui nous avons beaucoup de groupes
beaucoup d'écoles notamment et pas mal
de touristes qui viennent pour apprendre
l'histoire
danoise vous nous avez dit que c'est
l'un des premiers musées au monde où
l'on peut voir l'avatar d'une femme
venue tout droit de la préhistoire
oui elle vient de l'âge de bronze comme
on dit ici au Danemark c'est une sorte
d'icône dans le pays elle a été trouvée
en 1921 dans un vieux cercueil nous
l'avons préservé et maintenant elle
reprend
vie pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur
les Danois et leur
culture
la culture danoise est vraiment
particulière comme vous le savez car
c'est un petit pays aujourd'hui même
s'il a été bien plus grand auparavant
c'est un pays qui a sa propre monnaie et
nous aimons dire que nous avons une
culture
multiple qui dépend de là où nous vivons
de là d'où viennent nos
parents ques sont les spécificités des
Danois danois nous vivons dans une
société démocratique dans un
environnement
chaleureux et vous avez sans doute
entendu parler du HUG c'est quelque
chose de très spécial pour les
Danois ce sont des moments partagés avec
la famille ou les amis simplement des
bons moments de partage dans le
salon a beaucoup d'enfants au musée
comme vous l'avez dit comment
faites-vous pour qu'ils soi nombreux dès
le plus jeune âge à venir au
[Musique]
musée tous les enfants peuvent venir
gratuitement au musée que ce soit avec
l'école ou avec les parents nous avons
plusieurs activités pour eux et
notamment un musée spécial pour les
enfants avec plein de surprises cachées
un peu partout donc ils peuvent s'amuser
à les trouver et quelque chose de
magique souvent se passe il y a beaucoup
de choses pour eux à leur apprendre et à
découvrir en
fait et ce musée il fonctionne
bien oui et il est très populaire auprès
des
enfants sinon combien de personnees
visitent le musée chaque année cette
année environ 400000 mais c'est bien
plus car le musée national est un
regroupement de musées bien plus large
avec 21 musées un peu partout dans le
pays ça comprend aussi des châteaux mais
pour celui-ci on peut dire que c'est
notre plus gros musée dans le centre de
copenhag merci beaucoup m borit je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable des
expositions musé bonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ak
show I
[Applaudissements]
feel
[Musique]
see
see pls St
hon ja eller folk hon Var ex men det var
min jag V för
läe jag
m till
keep
allez c'est l'heure de la dégustation
avec un pain à la cannelle une base de
crème de beurre et de sucre ici on
appelle ça un pain à la Danoise mais en
vérité ça nous vient d'Autriche et ce
sont les fameux pains viennois zone
Europe sur sensation
8 danois sur 10 pensent que faire partie
de l'Union européenne est une bonne
chose 62 % ont une image positive de
l'Union européenne contre seulement 36 %
des Français alors pourquoi les Danois
sont-ils attachés à l'Europe j'ai
rendez-vous avec Maya Nilsen
vice-présidente des jeunes Européens
Danemark zone
Europe bonjour Maya Nelson bonjour merci
de nous recevoir ici dans Copenhague
avec vous on va parler de l'Europe à
travers la jeunesse alors est-ce que
vous pouvez déjà nous présenter votre
association oui bien sûr nous appelons
les jeunes européenne au denemark et ça
veut dire juste que c'est une
organisation pour les jeunesse au
denemark qui s'entér esse à l'Europe et
qui s'intéresse à l'Union européenne et
oui c'est une organisation de valeurs
européenne et on travaille pour diffuser
les visions Europ européennees par parmi
les jeunes au denemark alors vous avez
dit pour savoir si les jeunes
s'intéressent à l'Europe est-ce que les
jeunes ici s'intéressent à l'Europe
justement ouais vraiment vraiment
pourquoi comment pour ci oui on a
beaucoup de membres qui étudient quelque
chose avec l' r le l'économie les
questions des langues euh des sciences
politiques et grâce à leurs étude oui on
a beaucoup de membres qui qui souhaitent
travailler avec l'Union européenne et
pour beaucoup d'eux c'est une bonne
manière de de trouver une manière de
travailler avec ça et aussi de juste de
trouver une société avec des autas
jeunes qui s'intéressent la même chose
et justement cette relation elle a été
elle a commencé en 1973 le Danemark fait
partie de l'Union européenne depuis 73
quelle est votre vision de l'Europe ici
au Danemark euh bien sûr c'est c'est
plutô plus c'est c'était encore plus
sintégré
euh avec la coopération européenne parce
que au denmac on a cette cette je sais
vraiment comment dire en français mais
il s'appelle le stout en en anglais et
ça veut dire que le Danemark euh on n'
pas l'uro et on n'est pas parti de
l'auropol et c'est quelque chose qu'on
travaille vraiment pour euh supprimer
cet updout et que le Demar euh gagner
encore plus de de possibilités euh dans
l'Union oui c'est ça parce qu'il y a
plusieurs particularités vous avez parlé
de la monnaie il y a la couronne danoise
encore ici vous vous aimeriez passer à
l'euro ouisi oui vraiment Vim vent
pourquoi qu'est-ce que ça changerait
parce que c'est plus facile avec et
quand on quand on voyage il faut pas
oui oui sur les échanges monétaires oui
c'est ça c'est ça et aussi juste parce
que c'est symbolique pour moi aussi de
si le denemark a
l'Euro ça veut dire que ok tout le le
espace monétaire c'est aussi quelque
chose on voudrait vraiment travailler et
coopérer avec les autres pays européenes
et quand on n'est pas l'uro pour moi
c'est un peu ça veut dire que on n'est
pas prête à vraiment compltement
s'intégré à l'Union européenne ouis
totalement il y a d'autres exemples
notamment sur la politique de défense
commune avec l'Europe il y a eu des
choix qui ont été adoptés que très
récemment avec l'Europe comment est-ce
que vous expliquez que ça arrive comme
ça à retard de ici ça prend beaucoup de
temps parce
que je sais pas c'est juste parce que il
y a
cette cette idée au danemar qu'on a pas
vraiment besoin de l'Union européenne
beaucoup de monde pense que ok on est
parti de le Conseil nordique et ça c'est
ESS pour beaucoup de gens et si on
travaille avec la suette la novche et la
Finlande c'est ass on a pas besoin
d'autre chose mais euh pour nous en les
jeunes Européens on voit que ok c'est
pas assez de seulement faire ça et mais
oui je crois que c'est à cause de ça ça
prend beaucoup de temps parce que on a
cette idée que ok c'est ass on a pas
vraiment besoin de ça donc en fait c'est
plus générationnel finalement vraiment
ouais ou ça il y a une cassure entre les
génération oui oui en 2024 ça arrive
très rapidement il y a les élections
européennes h justemar dispose de 14
sièges au Parlement européen c'est pas
forcément énorme quand on sait que la
France et l'Allemagne par exemple en en
90 est-ce que vous avez l'impression
quand même que votre pays pèse quand
même dans les
décisions je crois que oui et bien sûr
on n pas vraiment beaucoup de cège ça
c'est dommage mais je crois aussi que
quand les Danois parlent on l' tend et
je suis très fier être danoise dans
l'Union mais
oui bien sûr euh on et on fait aussi
parti de le de frugal for de pays qui a
pas vraiment envie de payer euh beaucoup
d'Argens à le projet et moi je crois
aussi que c'est très dommage mais oui il
y a cette cette division entre les
Danois sont des peuples très sériueux
mais on veut aussi pas vraiment payer
mais oui et a un chiffre justement qui
montre que les Danois quand même
s'investissent dans cette cause
européenne d'après un récent sondage 86
% des Danois affirment qu'ils iront
voter aux élections européennes quand on
fait la la différence avec la France
c'est 60 % des Français seulement 6
Français sur 10 alors que prennent neu
danois sur 10 iront voter aux élections
européennes l'une des raisons pour les
Danois c'est qu'ils considèrent que
c'est leur devoir de citoyens est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres
raisons peut-être aussi pas parce que le
denemark c'est pas vraiment en grand
pays et tout le monde sait que si on
veut d'influence t s payer il faut voter
mais peut-être aussi plus parce que oui
on sait que c'est en en droit de
citoyens de voter mais ou peut-être
c'est aussi parce que toutes les
politiciens danois ils il soulignne
aussi que c'est vraiment important que
tous les Danois ils votent et aussi
aussi avec le jeun européen on va aussi
faire euh de campagnes de de dial de
danois que c'est vraiment
important qu'il bon alors pour finir cet
entretien on peut le dire les jeunes
sont très investis ici vous pensez donc
que le Danemark va s'insérer de plus en
plus dans l'Europe au fur à mesure des
années j'espère et je crois aussi que
oui parce que le jeunes ils savent
que l'Union c'est le futur de les jeunes
et on est déjà très fier d'être parti de
des choses comme Erasmus est être
capable deétudier dans des Ares pays et
à cause de ça les jeunes savent que ok
si on veut des choses bons comme des bon
choses comme Erasmus il faut aussi
s'entquer encore plus merci beaucoup
Nelson de nous avoir accueilli ici je
rappelle que vous êtes la
vice-présidente des jeunes européens au
Danemark merci
[Musique]
merci
capitano
[Musique]
c'estiziz
et comme tous les jours à midi ici sur
la place à malienbourg c'est l'heure de
la relève de la garde zone Europe sur
sensation programme Erasmus plus échange
scolaire voyage d'étude pourquoi choisir
le Danemark pour faire une mobilité nous
allons rencontrer Flavie elle a 21 ans
elle est originaire d'elbuf scène
maritime et elle fait des études en
digital management zone
Europe bonjour Flavie bonjour vous avez
21 ans et vous étudiez à l'école de
business de Copenhague en digital
management depuis août 2022 ça consiste
en quoi euh c'est assez similaire je
pense à une école de commerce en France
je dirais que la grosse différence c'est
surtout que déjà c'est gratuit toutes
les écoles de
commerce ça consiste en quoi j'ai des
cours environ 15h par
semaine principalement en amphithéâtre
quelquesuns en cours d' enfin exercice
exercise class donc vraiment
l'équivalent des
TD il y a beaucoup d'étudiants
internationaux ou pas dans votre classe
dans la classe on est environ 40 %
d'élèves
internationaux élèves internationaux je
compte aussi tout ce qui est suédois et
cetera donc ils se comprennent avec les
danwap globalement mais ouais 40 %
environ alors justement c'est
intéressant vous êtes en 2uxe année de
Bachelor et juste pour être sûr on est
ici au Danemark c'est une langue pas
forcément facile à comprendre vous
parlez anglais ou danois en cours
anglais anglais ouais quand on arrive la
semaine d'introduction on nous met tout
de suite dans le bas en nous disant que
l'objectif c'est que tout le monde parle
anglais tout le temps pour que tout le
monde se comprenne c'est pas forcément
le cas en
permanence mais la plupart des gens font
des efforts les cours sont en anglais
pour le pour mon diplôme en tout cas il
y a également des diplômes en danois mon
diplôme est complètement en anglais et
vous avez commencé à prendre quand même
le danois ou pas euh beaucoup de mes de
mes de mes camarades oui euh moi
seulement le vraiment la base de la base
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps pour ça
bon alors quelles sont les grandes
différences entre étudier en France et
étudier ici au Danemark
euh je pense une histoire d'horaire déjà
seulement 15 heur par semaine ça fait
pas
énorme en France quand j'ai fait une
année à l'université c'était beaucoup
plus que
ça forcément l'anglais euh ça fait ça
fait une différence au début c'est pas
forcément évident
euh
une grosse différence c'est qu'on a un
revenu étudiant pour les élèves
européens et en fait on on a un système
de statut égal au danois par le fait
d'être européen le principe c'est que on
doit travailler un minimum d'heure par
mois pour qu' s'assure qu'on paye nos
taxes évidemment et en échange on peut
être payé par mois un montant c'est 6000
couronnes donc c'est environ 800 € c'est
pas négligeable ce qui est pas du tout
négligeable vous avez en plus un job
justement un job étudiant à côté donc
c'est un rapport avec ça oui tout à fait
bah oui avoir un job c'est obligatoire
pour pouvoir avoir le SU donc le revenu
étudiant s'appelle le
SU donc je travaille dans un restaurant
thaïlandais depuis un peu plus d'un an
maintenant en tant que serveuse c'est
plutôt sympa je fais environ 15 heures
par semaine il faut 40 heur par mois de
travail au minimum donc j'ai mon nombre
d'heures suffisant ça fait un complément
c'est bien et alors quel est votre
rythme de vie plus généralement ici en
tant que je française ici au Danemark on
sait que les gens vivent un peu plus tôt
ici parce que la nuit tombe assez tôt
également ouais alors oui ça c'était un
peu au début j'ai eu un peu de mal les
gens mangent très tôt donc les
restaurants ferment aussi très tôt faut
pas s'y prendre à 22h pour aller
[Musique]
manger je pense que une différence c'est
forcément le temps je viens de Normandie
donc il fait c'est plus vieux mais pas
autant qu'ici ici c'est aussi beaucoup
de vent beaucoup de froid l'été est
sympa cependant donc ça fait ça fait le
contrecoup
[Musique]
euh en réalité je pense pas qu'il y a
énormément de c'est pas un dépaysement
total de venir ici euh c'est c'était pas
hyper compliqué de s'adapter ce qui
était compliqué c'était forcément les
démarches en anglais en danois et cetera
mais à part ça c'est pas c'est pas du
tout infaisable c'est pas très difficile
vous vous êtes senti donc bien accueilli
est-ce que quel est la différence entre
les Français et les Danois est-ce que
ils sont plus accueillants plus aimables
ou pas forcément les Danois sont très
accueillants euh par contre c'est très
difficile de lier des connexions
profondes avec eux en général ils ont
des amis depuis la petite enfance avec
qui il restent toute leur vie donc c'est
pas évident du tout de se faire des vra
vraiment des amis
danois je pense que actuellement j'ai
peut-être un ou deux amis danois le
reste c'est vraiment que des
internationaux donc ouais je pense que
ça c'est une vraie différence c'est
vraiment pas évident de de se connecter
vraiment avec les Danois et et c'est
quoi justement la vie avec entre amis
ici entre jeunes entre danois c'est ça
se passe comment j'adore aller dans les
cafés visiter les cafés aller boire un
verre il y a quelques boîtes sympas j'en
ai pas fait beaucoup ce semestre mais
l'année dernière on est pas mal sorti
l'école organise pas mal de trucs notre
union étudiante organise pas mal de
sorties ils organisent aussi des des ils
appellent ça DM dinner DM c'est pour
digit management et en fait c'est
simplement des gens qui se portent
volontaires pour pour hoster pour
accueillir
et les groupes sont dispatchés
aléatoirement et on prépare un repas
qu'on qu'on partage et ensuite à la fin
de la soirée donc on discute de de la
soirée avec des gens de de n'importe
quel âge du diplôme ça peut être des
dernière année ça peut être première
année peu importe et et à la fin on sort
en boîte ou juste on se dit au revoir
quoi donc c'est vraiment sympa ça permet
de rencontrer des gens dans tout le
diplôme quoi bon vous avez l'air de
vivre pleinement en tous les cas cette
expérience et en préparant cette
émission vous m'avez confié que votre
projet professionnel c'était ensuite de
travailler dans le milieu équestre avec
les les chevaux en quoi cette expérience
ici au Danemark peut vous aider à aller
vers ça euh j'aime aussi beaucoup tout
ce qui est digital donc mon mon
expérience est plutôt là-dessus que ça
va m'aider ce qui est peut ce qui peut
être utile dans absolument toutes les
industries donc en réalité pour aller
dans le milieu du cheval ce sera aucun
problème euh et justement ce semain j'ai
fait un stage dans une marque alors
c'est une marque norvégienne mais dont
les les bureaux sont situés à Copenhague
depuis cette année donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire un stage de 3 mois
là-bas en e-commerce donc pour le coup
j'alliais vraiment le le cheval et le
mon diplôme quoi et donc votre
expérience ici est loin d'être terminer
parce que vous êtes là donc depuis 2022
vous allez rester au minimum jusqu'en
juin 2025 ouais terminer mon
bachelore probablement faire un master
ici je ne sais pas encore lequel je sais
pas encore si c'est certain enfin ça
n'est pas certain euh et la suite je
sais pas j'aime beaucoup vivre ici donc
je me vois bien potentiellement rester
mais il y a aucune certitude et
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené pourquoi
avoir choisi le Danemark en fait euh je
voulais vraiment aller étudier à
l'étranger en anglais euh j'avais pas un
budget de de malade j'avais un peu de
d'argent de côté parce que j'avais
travaillé mais je pouvais pas me
permettre d'aller au d'aller en
Angleterre ou aux États-Unis ou ce genre
de de pays où il y a beaucoup de frais à
rentrer enfin les frais d'inscription
sont énormes et le marque c'est gratuit
tout les toutes les études ou presque
sont gratuites donc c'est vraiment
génial et il y avait aussi cette
histoire de su alors à la base je savais
pas si j'allais pouvoir l'avoir ou non
parce qu'il y a quand même quelques
critères du coup
mais c'était vraiment un énorme plus
parce que ça me permet la vie au
Danemark est très cher et ça me permet
de supporter ça vous recommandez cette
expérience à d'autres Français ouais
ouais complètement j'en avais jamais
entendu parler vraiment j'ai j'ai
trouvé ce cette université et le
Danemark vraiment par le fait de j'ai
vraiment juste fait des recherches parce
que je voulais partir à l'étranger j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un en France en parler
et je trouve ça dommage parce que il y a
vraiment une opportunité d'aller à
l'étranger même si on a pas énormément
de fond ou quelqu'un pour nous aider
derrière c'est possible quoi au Danemark
en tout cas c'est possible on a un
revenu étudiant et on peut vraiment on
peut vraiment vivre correctement ici
penser à son bonnet et à ses gants quand
même ou merci Flavi d'avoir été avec
nous de rien et on vous souhaite une
très bonne fin d'expérience ici au
Danemark nu vill VI Äl SK VI BR barikä
nu I
[Musique]
stjär
Jigen SNE F
påigen
[Musique]
koligen
restons dans cet esprit festif nous
sommes à l'école franco-danoise au
programme des échanges culturels un
concert de chanson française mais aussi
des rencontres avec des artistes
français installés ici depuis plusieurs
années ils sont en train de se préparer
on va les retrouver dans un
instant zone
Europe Marie astri bonsir bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes en charge de la
promotion de l'association chanson
française au Danemark c'est vous qui
organisez cette soirée parlez-nous en
s'il vous plaît oui tout à fait donc ce
soir c'est une soirée organisée donc
avec Magalie Michot et avec Frédéric
gonzalz en vue de de montrer un petit
peu ce qu'on ce qu'on fait ici au
Danemark pour les chansons françaises
donc c'est un des événements qu'on qu'on
cherche à promouvoir donc des quelques
concerts notamment bah des membres du
bureau récemment il y a eu un
concert avec des artistes aussi
francophones français ici au
Danemark où chaque chaque personne
venait chanter pendant trois quarts
d'heure il y a eu même un
dessinateur de la bande dessiné pzi qui
est aussi également français donc on
cherche vraiment à promouvoir les
chansons françaises à travers des
concerts mais pas que on organise
également aussi des karaokés donc on
rassemble à peu près entre 30 et 40
personnes pour chacun karaoké euh à la
fois des Français des francophones mais
aussi des Danois amoureux de la langue
française oui il y en a il y en a
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de danois qui
ont appris par le passé le français à
l'école et puis qui cherchent à le à
l'entretenir également vous avez
plusieurs casquettes aussi parce que
vous faites également partie d'une
troupe de théâtre Copen Act c'est du
théâtre en français ça parle de quoi
alors en fait j'ai j'ai repris un
atelier théâtre dans lequel je jouais il
y a 3 ans et tout s'était arrêté avec le
covid et on m'a donné demandé de
reprendre cet atelier et j'ai pas voulu
créer des ateliers pour adultes j'ai
voulu monter des pièces de théâtre donc
ça fait 2 ans que je monte des des
pièces de théâtre enfin une pièce de
théâtre par an et avec à chaque fois des
centaines donc de de personnes qui VI
voà bne centaines de personnes à chaque
représentation on a on a rassemblé plus
de 400 personnes cette année sur trois
représentations donc des comédies
dramatique pour les deux premières
années donc on a joué entre autres un
air de famille de niè Jaoui Jean-Pierre
Baker euh cette année c'était un petit
jeu sans conséquence et bon c'éit pour
la l'année 2024 ça sera une comédie
purure donc voilà donc j'ai choisi de
monter ces pièces de théâtre et de et de
mettre en scène en fait je me suis
lancée dans la mise en scène à la base
j'aime j'aimais jouer j'étais plutôt sur
scène et je me suis lancé dans la mise
en scène pour ces pièces de théâtre là
et euh là pour la nouvelle pièce je
remonte aussi sur scène donc je fais les
deux assister on vous souhaite le
meilleur merci beaucoup Maria
voilà et puis on va continuer parce que
si on est là ce soir c'est aussi pour un
concert allez c'est parti je veux
cal je veux du
silence je veux du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
CAL
desac bonsoir magadie Micho bonsoir
alors vous êtes présidente fondatrice de
l'association chanson française au
Danemark parlez-nous déjà de cette
association s'il vous plaît absolument
ben en fait moi je suis arrivée du coup
au Danemark en 2017 à l'été 2017 et puis
ben j'ai un petit peu observé ce qui se
passait et puis au fur à mesure j'ai eu
envie du coup début 2018 de bah de créer
cette association dans un but en fait de
rassembler les gens autour
de de la chanson française au sens large
et donc voilà un petit peu pour à la
fois promouvoir la chanson française ici
au
Danemark et puis et puis et puis mettre
en place des événements qui qui qui
puissent comme ça rassembler les gens
euh et aussi participer à certains
événements existants du point de vue de
la musique et vous quel est votre
rapport avec la musique justement euh
ben moi la musique bah j'en fait déjà
depuis que je suis toute petite je suis
violoniste à l'origine et j'ai fait les
études au conservatoir et puis là
maintenant depuis un petit nombre
d'années je je suis aussi autrice
compositrice interprète euh et donc je
voilà donc je pratique la musique aussi
sous cet
[Musique]
angle laisse pas
là
ohen V pas reste avec
moi alors depuis que vous êtes au
Danemark racontez-nous votre vie
d'artiste ici comment ça se passe alors
c'est vrai que faire de la chanson
française à copenhag c'est peut-être pas
forcément ce qu'il y a de plus naturel
mais d'autant que moi j'aiécris des
chansons vraiment où les textes sont
importants et donc c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est pas toujours facile de
d'être au contact avec un public qui va
pas toujours comprendre les paroles
euh mais d'une part il y a la musique de
la langue il y a des gens qui même en
ayant une compréhension un peu limité ou
même voir en ne comprenant pas du tout
le français qui me disent mais si si
chante en français c'est beaucoup plus
beau euh parce que j'ai aussi chanter en
anglais mais mais plus trop maintenant
et puis ben en fait j'ai aussi la chance
de de faire des concert alors pas mal
chez l'habitant euh il y a notamment une
plateforme ici au au Danemark qui
s'appelle be my concert anciennement LF
qui permet de mettre en lien comme ça
des gens qui souhaitent accueillir des
concerts chez eux et des artistes qui
veulent jouer donc ça me permet de jouer
dans les contextes
vraiment très intimes intimiste vraiment
où je prends ma guitare et puis je
chante les chansons et puis on est dans
le partage avec assez peu de personnes
et ça c'est assez enrichissant et du
coup il y a à la fois des expat de
français euh mais aussi beaucoup de
danois francophil voire francophon qui
ont une histoire avec la France et et
qui sont contents comme ça de de d'être
un peu au contact de la culture via les
les chansons en français n'a le droit en
vérité me blâer de me juger et je
précise que c'est bien la famille
qui est seul responsable
si je suis un
Tello comme il
[Musique]
dis vous avez votre CD impressionniste
c'est ça j'ai sorti mon premier album
l'année dernière ouais ouais
impressionniste euh donc en en
distribution physique hein le le petit
objet rond c'est une fierté déjà
j'imagine c'est votre premier oui oui
oui oui oui bien sûr oui j'en suis je
suis très contente c'est c'est tout un
chemin d'arriver jusque là enfin et puis
euh et puis c'est vrai que bah c'est
c'est toujours très agréable dans dans
des concerts en particulier des concerts
comme ceuxla de pouvoir ensuite échanger
et et que les gens puissent repartir
avec quelque chose avec un objet et avec
un petit bout de de chansons avec eux et
donc avec un livret avec les paroles et
cetera c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est
sympa aussi ouais on va en écouter
justement des des chansons ce soir un
dernier mot peut-être un un petit
conseil pour des Français pourquoi pas
qui se diraient si j'allais m'installer
au Danemark pour en vivre de la chanson
est-ce que vous auriez un conseil à leur
donner ouh là là
euh alors prendre de la vitamine
D non plus sérieusement je crois que bah
être être enthousiaste de de toutes les
découvertes qu'on peut faire et puis et
puis aller au devant des des gens que ce
soit la communauté francophone
francophile ou plus largement je crois
que c'est surtout ça c'est c'est la
découverte en fait de l'autre et des des
cultures qui sont intéressantes merci
Magalie Michot merci à vous et un autre
artiste français est également présent
ce soir on va le
découvrir
[Musique]
bonsoir
fré bonsoir on vous appelle aussi
Frédéric GK c'est votre nom de scène
c'est tout à fait ça vous êtes aussi
compositeur et interprète parlez-nous de
votre univers musical alors mais mon
univers va être assez large mes
références vont être plutôt Renault
Cabrel Jean-Jacques Goldman c'est
enfin voilà c'est ça c'est ça euh c'est
plutôt des mélodies soit en joué avec un
un texte en fonction j'ai des chansons à
texte plutôt plutôt dur et puis d'autres
un peu plus un peu plus légère tout
dépend de l'humeur et et comment ça
vient donc vous parlez de quoi dans vos
chansons euh et bien euh une de mes
chansons les plus récentes parl des euh
des à des massacres dans les écoles par
exemple je m'interroge un peu sur
qu'est-ce qui peut qu'est-ce qui peut
pousser quelqu'un à en arriver là
euh il y a également
euh l'impact que que que l'univers
autour de nous euh peut avoir sur les
enfants et comment en tant que parents
on peut communiquer sur euh les les
guerres aux alentours les les questions
de climat comment
comment gérer le dilemme entre vouloir
dire la vérité et en même
temps rester positif et passer un
message qui qui pas trop noir en fait
oua finalement des questions que tout le
monde peut se poser vous vous les mettez
en chanson donc et ça se passe plutôt
bien vous faites un duo désormais c'est
ça c'est ça donc j'ai rencontré merite
qui est ici
et euh à des cours quand on a commencé à
prendre quand j'ai commencé à prendre
des cours de guitare et de chant et et
puis depuis on joue ensemble parce que
vous ça fait presque un quart de siècle
que vous vivez ici au Danemark mais vous
êtes artiste depuis très peu finalement
depuis depuis 2 3 anss 2 3 ans voilà
j'ai commencé
en j'ai pris ma plus jeune fille qui
devait avoir 14 ans à l'époque qui et on
est allé à copenhag je suis parti
m'acheter une guitare et j'ai commencé à
me mettre sur des cours de bah des des
tutos en ligne pour apprendre le la
guitare jouer les premiers morceaux
ensuite prendre des cours euh avec Ben
des professeurs aux alentours je me suis
aussi j'ai passé des auditions pour
chanter les enfants étaient devenus
grands j'avais un peu plus de temps pour
pour moi et j'ai été pris dans un groupe
de rock j'ai commencé à chanter à jouer
de la guitare et puis ben j'ai pu
commencer à mettre des mélodies sur
tablature et puis commencer à à écrire
des textes et puis commencer à chanter
et et et jouer voilà il n'y aura
sûrement pas de voyage mais il sera
rester sage la vie a chois
autr est-ce que c'est c'est facile de
devenir artiste entre guillemets on sait
qu'il y a son l'administratif qui pose
problème est-ce que ici vous avez
rencontré des difficultés alors au
niveau administratif pas du tout euh ce
qui est difficile c'est de se lancer en
fait et je peux encourager n'importe qui
à à le faire
euh
parce que avant tout on le fait pour
soi-même si on peut toucher quelqu'un
dans le public c'est c'est fantastique
mais mais c'est un voyage qu'on fait ou
une espèce d'expérience qu'on fait
soi-même pour pour avancer et peu
importe l' finalement la reconversion
peut arriver à n'importe quel moment ah
oui complètement complètement est-ce que
vous aimez votre vie ici au Danemark ah
beaucoup qu'est-ce que vous aimez
qu'est-ce que j'aime j'aime le temps
avec ma famille
j'aime la relation au
travail une relation de confiance où ça
permet aux employés de de vraiment
donner le meilleur deeux-même sans être
contrôlé ce qui était un peu
l'expérience que j'avais moi pas mal
d'années en France
donc ça et puis le le temps pour le
développement personnel aussi on a des
journées assez compressées on commence
de bonne heure on a une courte pause le
midi mais le soir on finit relativement
de bonheure après nos 8h et quelques de
travail ce qui permet de prendre des
cours que ça soit de la céramique que ça
soit de la chanson de la guitare quoi
que ce soit et tout en ayant toujours le
temps pour pour sa famille donc ça
permet vraiment d'être beaucoup plus je
trouve plus complet alors après il faut
s'accommoder avec le le climat surtout
le bah il fait sombre assez souvent dès
qu'on arrive au mois de d'octobre
jusqu'au mois de février début mars
c'est dur mais si on peut survivre à ça
vous avez déjà fait une chanson sur le
climat justement ici ou pas encore pas
encore pas encore mais pourquoi pas ça
peut être une idée just comment combien
de temps est-ce que vous passez à
l'entraînement musical par jour par
semaine alors la guitare j'essaie d' de
jouer tous les jours que ça soit 10
minutes 1 heure tout dépend du temps que
que je vais avoir mais c'est une espèce
de routine et et c'est vrai que si si je
le fais pas ça me manque donc c'est une
une façon pour moi
de certaines personnes vont
aimer le potager ou autre moi ça me
permet de de de déstressé de la journée
de travail donc ça me permet de ou de me
retrouver merci beaucoup Frédéric
d'avoir été avec nous c'est moi qui vous
remercie Frédéric GK donc son nom
d'artiste et on va tout de suite écouter
ce que ça donne pour qu'
r pourvu qu'il soit
là
sob
[Musique]
ar
elsk
[Musique]
F
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant la période des fêtes vous
l'aurez remarqué copenhag se transforme
en une ville féque nous sommes ici à la
BR ice rink une patinoire de 600 m car
où on y trouve des dégustations mais
aussi beaucoup d'animations et c'est ce
qu'on va voir maintenant avec Clara
Anderson zone
Europe CLA Clara Anderson bonsoir
comment
allez-vous et bien oui très bien vous
êtes en charge de l'événemciel ici à la
patinoire
oui en France on a l'image que le
Danemark est un pays du Nord qui est
souvent sous la neige mais ce n'est pas
vraiment le cas en fait ici
pour la neige non en effet les
températures au Mar sont très élevé
enfin pas haut mais c'est suffisant pour
que la neige ne puisse pas tenir souvent
nous n'avons pas de neige en décembre
mais cette année nous avons commencé le
mois avec de la neige c'était vraiment
magique mais ce n'est pas quelque chose
de
courant
SEM bien gér avec des températures pr
enous de0 les Danois sontil à l'aise
avec la
glace oui
plutôt par exemple j'ai grandi à
proximité d'un lac cha hiver il faisait
très froid et donc le lac étaité patiner
dessus c'était très cool mais ces
dernières années ce n'est plus vraiment
possible avec des températures qui ont
pas mal
augmenté je peux quand même affirmer que
les Danois sont plutôt à l'aise avec le
fait de glisser car nous avons aussi
beaucoup d'endroits où on peut patiner
donc oui c'est une chose plutôt courante
oui
etteiré latinoire pouvez-v nous
expliquer l'événement autour de la
[Musique]
saine c'est un événement que nous
célébrons chaque année le 13
décembre
[Musique]
cette année nous avons eu une couronne
de saintelcie et un ch sur glace en
collaboration avec un club
local il y avait 18 patineurs et
patineuses chaque année c'est très
agréable de venir et de profiter de ce
spectacle dans la soirée il y a aussi un
défilé de kayak sur le canal c'est super
beau
en effet l'atmosphère semble chaleureuse
et convivi puisquil n'y a pas que la
patinoire parlenous du
site le site ICI et bien nous sommes
ouverts de novembre à
février mais c'est vrai que mois de
décembre estul
l'atmosphère est super bonne nous avons
beaucoup de visiteurs beaucoup de
boissons
chaudes c'est un endroit pour être tous
ensemble en famille mais aussi enre
amis nous aimons ce genre d'endroit
partagé avec tout le monde donc
l'atmosphère est souvent très bonne
ici tout le temps Mme même si on n pas
super bon sur la glacee pr un chocolat
chaud par exemple oui
totalement Clara ça fait un long moment
que je n'ai pas patiné sur la glace quel
conseil pouvez-vous me
donner le meilleur des conseils c'est ne
tombe pas non plus sérieusement quand tu
es sur la glace sur la neige ou que tu
fais du roller il ne faut pas avoir peur
n'ai pas peur juste fais-le
fais-le je pense que c'est le meilleur
avis que je peux te donner donc ne
réfléchis pas trop et
amuse-toi donc je vais le
[Musique]
faire
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
tv78 à très bientôt bonne
soirée zone Europe sur
sensation